take a deep breath
there are about 56 stilian atoms in
every breath that you breathe in that's
a five followed by 22 zeros seven
octilian atoms make up your body that's
a seven followed by 27 zeros the whole
of planet Earth is composed of 100
quindicillion atoms or a one followed by
50 zeros in the entire observable
universe 46 billion light years across
there are thought to be up to 100
000 quadrillion vigintillion atoms or
one followed by 82 zeros
and the biggest number in the cosmos can
actually be arrived at by dividing the
total volume of the observable universe
by the smallest possible unit of volume
the Planck space
fighting everything we can we can see
into minuscule cubes we end up with 1
times 10 to the power of 185.
of those cubes
and yet that is not yet the biggest
number that humans have conceived
take for example the Goliath that is
tree three
as Antonio Padilla physicist at
Nottingham University puts it everything
you think you know
is dwarfed into nothing
welcome to the game of trees
you start with a colored seed which can
give rise to a tree whose branches and
in seeds that can Sprout their own trees
the goal is to make as many trees as
possible and there are two main rules
the first tree must contain one seed the
second a maximum of two seeds the third
a maximum of three seeds and so on at
each level the tree can contain less
than the maximum number but that maximum
is fixed to correspond to the level
you're at secondly the game ends and the
forest dies if you create a tree that
already exists within the forest so if
you repeat a pattern of colored seeds
that are linked together no matter how
far away it is in the forest it is game
over mathematicians have played this
game with different numbers of seed
colors tree one allows only a Single
Seed color and the forest dies at the
first tree the second seed you add is
necessarily a repeat of the first tree
two canasta Three Trees starting with
one color you make a tree that contains
two branches both of a second color the
next tree has just one branch by The
Next Step all possible combinations of
two colors have already been used and
you can't avoid building a tree that's
already been seen
but then you come to tree three
uses three colors
and tree three is different whereas the
previous forests died disappointingly
quickly a forest of three colored seeds
grows for an extraordinarily long time
mathematicians have proved the game must
end at some point but they've not been
able to count the trees it would take to
get there they've not been able to
because if they did
their brains would implode as Antonio
Padilla goes on to say in his
exploration of huge numbers for a while
you feel nothing untoward a string of
digits growing larger and larger in your
mind's eye and then it happens
just trying to imagine a number that
large is more than the human brain can
take trying to hold that number of
digits in your head would result in a
black hole forming from the sheer
quantity of information crammed inside
indeed faced with all the digits of tree
three scientists believe that the entire
observable universe will also suffer the
same fate
and so the solution to tree three is
without a doubt a mind-bendingly
enormous number but it is still a finite
number and so it is still smaller than
infinity
in fact however big the solution to tree
three is it is much much closer to zero
than it is to Infinity whereas counting
to the top of tree three may be a
foolish thing to attempt it isn't futile
because there is an end but Infinity has
no end
it just keeps going without reprieve for
every digit every object every anything
no matter how large there is another
waiting in line and another and another
so what happens when you keep going
is the universe itself infinite
and what would it mean to live in a
universe that never ended
take a deep breath
things
are about to get weird
foreign
Albert Einstein once said that politics
is more difficult than physics ground
news have kindly supported this video
and they are the world's first news
comparison platform because though
Einstein was exaggerating a little
discovering the truth behind what your
reading has become much more difficult
since Einstein's time we are constantly
bombarded by misinformation and news
with a specific agenda especially online
ground news is the solution to clickbait
news they make it easy to swipe between
headlines to discover which details are
emphasized exaggerated or left out
entirely the app has become an essential
tool for me and one that I've been using
for a while now as someone who believes
in objectivity and critical thinking I
find it a lifesaver when finding the
truth behind a story they have great
tools like the factuality score bias
distribution and media ownership data so
you can find out who is behind your news
you can even have it scan your Twitter
or Reddit feed to find out your own bias
so if you're looking for a better way to
stay informed about current events
around the world check out ground news
by visiting ground.news forward slash
hotu thanks to ground news for
supporting education on YouTube
around 530 BC in the small town of
Croton in southern Italy a secretive
Band of Brothers Meats in a lamplet room
whispering in hushed tones while they
wait for their illustrious leader to
make his appearance
their conversation is impassioned and
reverential like that of any cult but
these men do not speak of gods their
concern is with the human soul with
geometry and above all else
with numbers
as their Master emerges from the Shadows
his disciples fall silent to better hear
his latest Doctrine for everything that
the great Pythagoras utters must be the
absolute truth
foreign
wasn't uncommon for Scholars and their
students to worship philosophical and
mathematical Concepts but the
pythagoreans took things to a new level
believing in the transmigration of the
human soul into the bodies of animals
followers were strictly forbidden to eat
meat as such the Cults were thought to
be among the first ever vegetarians
although this would have been a
challenge as they believed a small part
of a man's Soul was lost every time he
passed gas Pythagoras preached that the
only escape from this endless cycle of
death and animalistic reincarnation was
to seek higher knowledge of the universe
and so the pythagoreans built a Doctrine
around numbers in their reverence of the
rational the pythagoreans sought to
support their worldview by demonstrating
the utility of the counting numbers 1 2
3 4 and so on whereas on wieldy
ungraspable irrational numbers were evil
defined by darkness and maleficence in
the cosmic battle of light over darkness
that which was unlimited was to be
abhorred and avoided at all costs
but it was in Geometry that the
Pythagorean Doctrine began to crumble
the closer they looked the more they
realized that not everything could be
explained so simply when attempting to
calculate the length of a Square's
diagonal there was no neat and tidy
solution that equated it to a ratio of
two counting numbers the results was
always irrational always inelegant
perpetually troubling the one thing that
carried Pythagoras's name down through
the centuries the calculation of
diagonals in squares and triangles is
the very thing that caused his cult such
discomfort
[Music]
irrational numbers were an unavoidable
part of our reality however disturbing
that was and among all numbers none was
more disturbing than infinity over the
coming centuries philosophers who were
not so rigid in their mathematical
Doctrine as the pythagoreans began to
contemplate the concept of the truly
Limitless
take for example xenos Paradox named for
another ancient Greek picture any
Journey you must complete like the
journey home after a long day at work in
order to go home you must first travel
half the way there then to cover the
remaining distance you first have to
travel half of it bringing you three
quarters of the way home traveling half
of the next stretch completes 7 8 of the
journey and the next half brings you 15
16 of the way home following this
principle of splitting each stretch of
the journey into halves you can continue
traveling halves an infinite number of
times and never reach your destination
this situation wouldn't happen in
reality of course you would make it home
after work eventually but there is no
doubting the logic of these infinite
divisions many Greeks tried to reconcile
this by relegating concepts of the
infinite to the Divine and metaphysical
claiming that they weren't a part of the
rational World however others tried to
categorize Infinities themselves there
was a difference they claimed between an
actual Infinity which is an infinite
quantity of things that exist all at
once and a potential Infinity which only
comes into existence as a result of a
process so counting to infinity or
subdividing a journey an infinite number
of times a potential Infinities whereas
actual Infinities like an infinitely
large object was still despised and
refuted they were simply impossible
some 2500 years have since passed since
this ancient introspection and with it
has come waves of mathematical and
scholarly advancement no longer tied to
Cults or secret societies numbers could
be analyzed for what they really were
rather than what they signified and the
same was true for our ideas of infinity
marked by a huge leap forward in the
late 19th century by a German
mathematician named Georg Cantor
Cantor was the first to consider that
there truly are different kinds of
infinity he described how there are an
infinite number of counting numbers but
also an infinite number of even numbers
too both groups are infinite in size
despite the fact that the list of
counting numbers completely contains the
list of even numbers plus the odd
numbers as well this apparent Paradox is
possible purely because of the bizarre
nature of infinity each of the even
numbers can be put in a numbered list
paired with a corresponding counting
number so 2 is number one four is number
two six is number three and so on right
up to Infinity you'll always be able to
match an even number to a counting
number so they are both the same size
but Cantor also showed that there are
actually Infinities of different sizes
when you consider subsets within an
infinite number of counting numbers take
the four members of The Beatles John
Paul George and Ringo how many different
combinations or subsets of members could
you form from among this group you could
have each of the four by themselves
pairs like John and Ringo or Paul and
George trios like John Paul and Ringo
and you can have a set of Zero no
Beatles at all in total There are 16
possible configurations of the four
Beatles many more than the original
number
same applies to Infinity
because of this multiplying nature of
subsets there will always be more
subsets than there are counting numbers
there are indeed infinite sets of
infinite counting numbers but one
Infinity is necessarily larger than the
other if you find this to be twisting
your brain to Breaking Point you're not
alone Georg Cantor himself suffered
several nervous breakdowns over the
course of his career and spent the last
year of his life in a mental hospital
nevertheless we must continue to
consider the infinite if we hope to
understand the past present and future
of the cosmos
for all their complexity cantor's
transfinite mathematics and the Greek's
desperate reasoning with impossible
paradoxes were limited to the
contemplation of numbers alone the
Greeks desperately tried to avoid any
contact between the infinite and reality
but astronomers Now find themselves
confronted with actual Infinities at a
return from the infinite densities at
the heart of supermassive black holes to
the potentially infinite expanse of the
universe as a whole scientists are now
equipped with the mathematical and
practical tools to tackle these problems
head on and face the many Oddities of an
infinite Cosmos and what they would mean
for our tiny fleeting existence
[Music]
foreign
s his home with weary eyes as he pushes
through the undergrowth on North
Sentinel Island brushing his hand
lightly across the leaves as he passes
he recognizes each of the trees bushes
and craggy rocks they are as familiar as
the faces of his children
gradually the trees thin and open out to
a Sandy Beach Beyond which is a vast
expanse of blue
he knows this land this speech he's even
fished from his boat in the shallow
Waters not far from Shore but the ocean
extends far further than the shallow
canoe will ever be able to carry him it
plunges to dark and unfathomable depths
and it stretches out and encircles his
island with a solid Halo of blue
this is the man's entire universe
the island is his world and everything
he can see is all there is
and yet
one afternoon when he and his companions
are bringing in the day's meager catch
something new arrives in the man's
Universe it's a white Speck at first too
small to make out at the edge of the
ocean it gradually grows in size as it
approaches the island and before long it
casts its long Shadow into the fishing
Waters the young man and his brothers
are justifiably terrified of these new
alien beings that have descended
silently into their world they throw
rocks and sticks at the gigantic vessel
before retreating back under the cover
of trees
had the sentence man been focused on
anything other than repelling the
immediate danger a flicker of curiosity
may have come to him if the island and
its ringing ocean was all there was then
where did these aliens and their giant
vessel come from if he appeared back out
from the safety of the trees at the end
of the day he would have seen the white
boat shrink and then disappear Beyond
the Horizon of the man's own universe
was there a vast expanse that lay Beyond
his own observable Cosmos
foreign
[Music]
ists and philosophers have long grappled
with the concept of an observable
universe and what if anything lies
Beyond as early as the 4th Century BC
the Greek scholar architus considered
what it would be like to travel to the
edge of the heavens and then extend his
hand out beyond the limit there could be
nothing greater than the heavens
themselves and so this he claimed
clearly implied a space Without Limits
and essentially infinite Universe in the
16th century Italian philosopher
Giordano Bruno also concluded that space
was infinite and contained infinitely
many things a statement that
unfortunately for him anchored the
church Bruno was captured tortured and
eventually burnt to the stake never had
contemplating Infinity being so mortally
dangerous and so in the following
Century the English philosopher Thomas
Hobbes came to a much more acceptable
conclusion on the nature of the infinite
Universe it was meaningless to speculate
he said whether there is or is not an
info not cause most beyond what we can
see because there's simply nothing we
can do to measure it better to put the
idea to bed and concern ourselves with
the many Mysteries that we can see
rather than those we never will whether
through self-preservation or Genuine
conviction his assertions have echoed
down through the centuries and are still
repeated by scientists to this day
why speculate when nothing good can come
of it although you're unlikely to lose
your life over the matter these days you
may still lose your mind nevertheless a
few Brave cosmologists still choose to
risk befuddlement in tackling the
potentially unknowable today we have
better tools than ever to probe the
observable universe and centuries of
science mathematics and philosophy to
cling on to as we contemplate the
potentially infinite reality of what
lies Beyond
like the tribes of North Sentinel Island
our view of the cosmos is limited by how
far we can see within it light never
travels faster than about 300 million
meters per second and so the further we
look in Space the further we are looking
back in time we can see galaxies from 1
billion years ago from 5 billion years
ago even from 10 billion years ago but
at a certain distance the light Fades
away we see no more galaxies because
this long ago there were not yet any
galaxies to be seen the edge of our
observable universe is therefore defined
as much by time as it is by space it is
not a physical construct just a
measurement of how fast light can travel
and the distance to that edge is further
defined by the expansion that has taken
place since those first galaxies started
growing their light has been traveling
for 13.8 billion years so they are at
least 13.8 billion light years away but
in the intervening period space has
continued to expand and so those first
galaxies are now some 46 billion light
years distant
though when we probe the limits of our
observable universe it is very clear
just how little the edges look like
edges
[Music]
there is nothing in the structure or
distribution of these distant galaxies
to suggest they're all piled up against
an invisible barrier even though it is
vanishingly unlikely that the cosmos
began with a perfectly even distribution
of matter and energy on the broadest
scale that is what we see there is no
Center to the universe on scales above
about 230 light years wherever we look
there are no places that are any hotter
colder or more or less densely clustered
with galaxies than anywhere else using
the cosmic microwave background a
universe-wide Afterglow from just 300
000 years after the big bang
affectionately known as the universe's
baby picture scientists have found
differences on the largest scales of
barely a couple of parts in a hundred
thousand in fact this homogeneity is
considered strong evidence for the
cosmological period of in inflation a
fraction of a second at the beginning of
time when the universe is believed to
have doubled in size some 80 times thus
expanding away many of its smaller
wrinkles
and so by taking inflation and its
resulting homogeneity into account this
despite the vastness of a universe 92
billion light years in diameter it
really must be much much larger if it is
to contain the inevitable irregularities
via the universe as Thomas Hobbes said
though there is nothing we can do to
probe that distant expanse and no amount
of modern technology would change that
We Are Forever limited by the speed of
light
but we do have an almost infinite
capacity for imagination
and meaningless or not we can speculate
about exactly what
lies Beyond
in general there is still an overarching
aversion to the concept of an infinite
universe and cosmologists are doing all
they can to find a mechanism that puts
limits on the amount of stuff out there
but how can you build a finite Universe
without invoking something Beyond
How can there be limits without an edge
for that there is at least one potential
explanation
if the sentinelese tribes man were to
take his canoe out into the unforgiving
open ocean Beyond the Horizon and onto
the great blue sea he could travel for
years without ever reaching a precipice
with favorable winds and currents he
would eventually find himself back at
North Sentinel Island having fully
circled the globe but without ever
having reached an edge just as the 2D
surface of the Earth is finite without
edges because it curves back on itself
so cosmologists suggest that the 3D
universe is also curved and is similarly
limited without margins
and this is something we can actually
test
on any flat surface two lines that start
out parallel to one another always
remain so they never touch and they
never diverge on a positively curved
surface like the surface of the Earth
lines that start off parallel will
eventually converge and touch one
another and on a negatively curved
surface like on a saddle then parallel
lines will gradually diverge moving
further and further apart in the 1930s
Edwin Hubble attempted to apply this
reasoning to the three-dimensional
Universe by counting the number of
galaxies he could see along a certain
sight line recording how that number
changed with distance it seems like a
sensible approach but in reality the
universe is not so simple as we look to
Greater distances within the cosmos we
look back in time and the inevitable
evolution of galaxies through time is
sure to have an effect on the counts at
different distances
but there are other ways of
investigating the same geometric
principle using more standard and
predictable features of the universe
the explosion in cosmological science
since the 1990s has equipped astronomers
with their best tools yet to try to
probe the unknowable vastness of the
universe beyond our grasp using
so-called standard candles and standard
rulers made up respectively of intensely
bright supernovae and sound waves from
the early Universe Frozen in place by
the formation of atoms astronomers
compare their models of the shape of the
universe with what we actually observe
in the skies powerful space telescopes
like wmap the Wilkinson microwave
anisotropy probe have measured the
precise mass of all the matter and
energy in the universe and compared it
with critical masses that would result
in Eternal expansion or inevitable
contraction we've even probed the tiny
irregularities and the cosmic microwave
background in search of any hint of
curvature either a positively or
negatively curved space-time would give
limits to the ultimate size of the
cosmos even a comp surface of positive
and negative curvature in different
directions could help Define the
edgeless boundaries of a finite universe
but when cosmologists actually make
these measurements they are consistently
finding a troubling pattern
as far as we can tell regardless of
where we look or how we look the
universe appears to be flat it extends
off in all directions with no hint of
hill or Valley
does that mean it goes on
forever
at first glance it certainly seems so
but then again at first glance the ocean
seems flat extending out endlessly in
every direction if we could just get
another perspective Say by Soaring
higher than the average passenger plane
we would be able to see that same ocean
curve around it has a positive curvature
that our surface-bound eyes can simply
not resolve and scientists are similarly
limited by the resolution of their
instruments
there are plenty of technical challenges
to observing distant Cosmic phenomena
from our planet and our very best
observations are only accurate to a
Precision of one in 400 that means that
while the universe may be flat as far as
we can see perhaps we aren't soaring
high enough to get the full picture but
at the very least the flatness we've
observed so far puts a lower limit on
the size of the unobservable universe
for it to be curved and yet still look
flat it must be at least 37 trillion
light years in diameter it is an immense
distance some thousand times larger than
our observable bubble but that is just
the smallest it can be
it could be much much bigger
[Music]
it could
be infinite
[Music]
on the 15th of August 1977 a volunteer
astronomer was reviewing pages of data
from the Big Ear radio telescope at Ohio
State University when he saw something
that made him stop in his tracks
in the days before widespread computer
processing The Observatory recorded and
printed out the signals it received
every 12 seconds indicating increasing
strength with first the numbers 0 to 9
and then letters of the alphabet A to Z
so when Jerry Ayman saw the sequence 6eq
uj5 he was actually seeing a distinctive
spike in radio noise a spike larger than
anything the telescope had seen before
knowing what such a narrow and isolated
beep from the sky could mean he circled
the characters and wrote wow alongside
and to this day the isolated radio
scream is known as the wow signal
at the time Big Ear was tasked with
listening for signals from Alien
civilizations as part of the growing
search for extraterrestrial intelligence
known as seti scientists had no good
idea of what a message from the Stars
might sound like but they knew it must
be clearly distinct from the usual
sounds of space which was exactly what
Eamon spotted
the wow signal was loud never repeated
and couldn't be traced to any visible
phenomena in the night sky was this our
first and only indication of alien life
in our galaxy to this day the signal
remains a mystery though most scientists
think it's more likely that the pulse of
radio waves came from a natural rather
than alien-mate Source but even if the
wow signal turned out to be a cosmic
fluke one of the odd quirks of an
infinite universe is that aliens would
most definitely
be real
microbes Little Green Men even vast
Galaxy devouring monsters simply put in
an infinite Universe not only is
everything possible
everything
is
attempting to filter this vague
statement through a scientific lens the
physicist Sean Carroll suggests that
there are four options number one the
universe is finite in size and finite in
time number two the universe is infinite
in size but finite in time number three
the universe could be finite in space
but last forever and that before perhaps
most bafflingly the universe could be
both infinite in size and infinite in
time
to start with let us consider a universe
of infinite size and finite time this
universe must surely contain endless
nothing but just as there are infinite
even numbers and infinite counting
numbers there can be infinite emptiness
and infinite structure all at the same
time that in itself is enough to confuse
but the true oddness begins when
considering what exactly makes up that
infinite structure
considering first the phenomena that we
can already observe things like stars
galaxies planets and life these would be
among the objects that presumably would
exist in infinite numbers across a
cosmos of infinite size this means that
there would be infinite configurations
of stars galaxies planets and living
beings out there more than we can ever
hope to count chart or travel to even if
by some small possibility the only life
that exists in the observable universe
is on one small rocky planet around a
four and a half billion year old yellow
star then this alone is enough to make
the list a phenomena that must be
repeated add infinitum throughout the
cosmos
indeed there must be an infinite number
of clones of each and every one of us
each contemplating their own place in
the Eternal universe and infinite
variations cosmologist Max tegmark
estimates that they would be something
like 10 to the power of 118 meters away
from us factoring in the possibility of
an infinite number of different
phenomena Things become even weirder
literally anything you can imagine and
an infinite number of other things
Beyond could be happening must be
happening in the universe at any given
time indeed quantum mechanics means that
anything within the known laws of
physics is possible at any time though
many of these possibilities are
statistically incredibly unlikely but
this is no impediment to a universe of
infinite size from cups falling through
solid tables to entire galaxies
appearing and disappearing in the blink
of an eye anything everything and all in
between would pop populate this zoo of
oddities and again just as with cantor's
even and counting numbers all
possibilities would happen an infinite
number of times no matter their
statistical likelihood
and in a universe of finite size but
infinite time much the same would apply
infinite times over if our universe
simply keeps expanding at its current
rate and its entropy keeps Rising then
we would once again be left victim to
Quantum weirdness as particles would pop
in and out of existence though again
statistically very unlikely within
infinite time everything would happen
infinitely often from single particles
appearing in the vacuum to entire brains
or more specifically body thus human
brains drifting alone through space
these so-called boltzmann brains are
part of a grim thought experiment named
for the late 19th century scientist
Ludwig boltzmann it may seem vanishingly
unlikely that the vroid of space could
create a human brain replete with
thoughts and artificial Sensations and
memories but due to the bizareness of
quantum fluctuations it really is one of
the mutations that an infinite Universe
can cycle through given enough time this
seemingly impossible permutation could
spontaneously appear and of course given
an even longer amount of Timeless time
it could even happen over and over again
it follows that statistically our
thoughts and experiences are much more
likely to be an illusion of a fictitious
Universe conjured up by a non-corporeal
boltzmann brain than they are true
reflections of the cosmos so close to
its birth
foreign
also suggests that the universe may
reach its poincare a recurrence time
after about 10 to the power of 10 to the
power of 120 billion years this would be
the moment when statistically all the
particles within a finite Universe would
repeat their initial arrangement
and so the cycle would begin again
and finally we arrive to an endless
universe of infinite size which comes
with its own challenges
Chief among them the measure problem
in a universe of infinite possibilities
each happening infinitely often how can
we ever calculate the probabilities or
ratios of anything how can we ever truly
know the laws of a universe in which
anything is possible and equally
infinite and so in this sense trying to
use the observable universe as any kind
of template for how the infinite Beyond
May function is a lost cause we might
imagine that the parts of the Eternal
universe that we can see may represent a
very small percentage of the whole but
the nature of infinity is such that any
fraction of it is essentially zero
all we have ever known will ever know or
could ever hope to know would be exactly
zero percent of the infinite Cosmos
under such conditions the very field of
cosmology becomes meaningless
predictions are impossible our theories
about the Big Bang the laws of nature
and the far future of our universe
simply hold no water because we know
precisely nothing about the infinite
Cosmos from which it arose
the enigmas themselves are unknown
unknowable and infinite in extent does
that mean that our very lives are
meaningless it's not hard to see why the
Greeks backed away from the concept of
infinity and all it entailed some 2000
years since they strove to reason
themselves out of an infinitely deep
Chasm we still find ourselves grappling
with the same problems despite the
development of trans-finite mathematics
a better than ever characterization of
what exactly is infinity and every
measure we can hope to conjure to study
the potentially infinite Cosmos on our
doorstep we really are no closer to
understanding anything about this number
Beyond numbers confronting Infinity
means confronting an inescapable
existential dilemma
but even this is not the end our own
Universe infinite or not is just the
beginning when it comes to grappling
with infinity in cosmological theories
there are many other perhaps even more
discomforting Infinities lurking over
their own impossible Horizons Infinities
that dwell inside of us Infinities
lingering in the distant past and
Infinities bubbling endlessly inside
larger
infinities
polish-born mathematician Benoit
mandelbrot was fascinated by the
apparent chaos of the natural and
man-made world and sought to find order
in everything from the fluctuations of
the financial markets to the shape of a
rocky Coastline and in 1958 moving to
New York State he found himself in the
perfect place to pursue his curiosity
the IBM Research Center in Yorktown
Heights had been created to help the
computer company develop its hardware
and software as well as the new kind of
mathematics that lay behind its computer
systems mandelbrot ended up staying
there for 35 years but his work didn't
focus on improving the computers rather
he demonstrated what the computers could
do for the field of maths itself and so
in 1980 he was among the first to use
computer Graphics to visualize something
that simply wouldn't be possible with
just pen and paper using relatively
simple equations he managed to display a
unique kind of geometry which he
referred to as fractal after the Latin
word for broken or shattered glass and
which is defined by its self-similar
structure independent of scale this
means that regardless of the scale
that's observed at a fractal will always
contain more detail you can zoom in or
out infinitely without ever reaching a
more simple geometry have infinite
complexity
mandelbrot showed this with his
computer-generated mandelbrot set but he
also observed how such fractals can be
found in nature similar fractal scale
independent geometry can be seen in the
leaves of ferns the head of Romanesque
broccoli even in the clustering of
distant galaxies
was the entire universe a fractal
of course we now know this is not the
case in our observable universe on the
largest scales we can examine
homogeneity Reigns but could there be
parallels on scales even larger
the question of how far the universe
extends beyond our bubble may not be
answerable right now but even if we
begin our cosmological studies with what
we can see it's not long before we bump
against the concept of infinity once
again
our universe is expanding everything is
moving away from everything else growing
like a loaf of bread in a warm oven if
it began from an infinite point then our
observable universe began as a finite
part of that initial infinite point and
again although our observable universe
grows bigger and bigger this is just a
measurement of how far the light has
traveled over time the actual physical
Universe has just become less and less
dense
larger objects like us and galaxies are
held together by gravity but wherever we
look across the cosmos Bara local group
every other Galaxy is moving further and
further away at an average rate of 70
kilometers per second per megaparsec
continue the trend of expansion into the
far future and what do we find unless
some as yet invisible force comes into
play we can expect that space-time will
continue to stretch pushing every Galaxy
away from its neighbors Stars away from
one another and eventually leading to a
universe-wide heat death
but despite this there is no final event
to bring the universe to a close our
observable universe will keep expanding
until it becomes infinitely large and
again because of the nature of
Infinities this will take an infinite
amount of time and yet
counter-intuitively even if we had this
infinite time we could only ever explore
a finite part of an infinite universe as
expansion would always be one step ahead
as we trace the universe back through
its history that expansion also reverses
and as we rewind the clock the cosmos
shrinks down becoming smaller denser and
hotter until it no longer resembles
anything like the universe we know the
laws of physics begin to act in bizarre
and unexpected ways allowing
cosmologists to make surprising
conclusions about exactly how things
began
the problem lies in actually identifying
that starting point
we can only understand the universe once
it reaches the size where our physical
laws mean anything which physicists
recognize today as the moment when the
cosmos was around one Planck length in
diameter according to the early 20th
century physicist Max Planck's
calculations the eponymous plank length
measures a minuscule 1.6 times 10 to the
minus 35 meters a decillionth of a
millimeter and is about a billion
trillion times smaller than an atomic
nucleus it is the size at which Quantum
uncertainty causes our known physics to
break down but the universe may well
have been expanding prior to this
blooming outwards from a point that was
infinitely small infinitely dense and
infinitely hot of course we have no idea
what this might look like or how it
might behave but there's nothing in what
we see and what we model to suggest
there was any other kind of beginning of
course the nature of Infinities means
that in order to compress the universe
down onto a primordial state that is
infinitely small it would take an
infinite amount of time which means that
our observable universe may well be much
much older than the 13.8 billion years
we calculate indeed at the big bang it
may already have been infinitely old and
So based on simple observations of how
the universe is now we cannot escape the
unprovable but as yet not disproven
logic of unbounded expansion both
backwards and forwards in time how then
can we reconcile our models of the big
bang and the inference of infinite
smallness with the inescapable logic of
infinite largeness
it's true that the observable universe
is expanding right now but that need not
be the case for the entire infinite
universe or for all of infinite time
cosmologists have suggested that our
local Universe consisting of the parts
we can see and an unknowable amount
Beyond are regions of limited inflation
within an immortal and infinite whole
this is the theory of Eternal inflation
first mooted in 1979 by Alan Guth and
given its Eternal elements in the early
80s by Andre Linde Andreas Albrecht and
Paul steinhardt we would therefore be
one minuscule part of an eternal
Universe where inflation may be always
happening but not necessarily always at
the same time in the same place or to
the same degree and The Logical
implication of this is that our universe
is one of infinitely many bubble
universes that have spontaneously
germinated and bloomed from the endless
whole each of these corners of the
infant that Multiverse May sit at
different stages of cosmological
development and may be ruled by physical
laws very different to our own but they
will forever be beyond our grasp
separated by the uncrossable Gulf of
Infinite Space
and so exploring the patchwork world of
Multiverse theories opens up a further
Pandora's box of infinities
in order to accommodate the Exotic
physics that the infinitely small
requires many physicists delve into the
world of possibilities offered by
various string theories and M Theory in
this Theory it is claimed that our
reality exists as a fleeting
intersection of dimensions and that many
such juxtapositions might exist
simultaneously and pass in and out of
existence as the larger bulk of
hyperspace transforms so we must
contemplate not only the notion of
infinite universes in our three
dimensions of space but also the
existence of a Multiverse made from any
number of dimensional combinations and
again there is nothing to say that these
different universes would have the same
laws of physics as our own which of
course opens up a whole new frontier of
infinite options different strengths of
gravity different masses of fundamental
particles truly endless possibilities
our big bang may be the smallest scale
that we can resolve and the ultimate
heat death of the universe may be the
largest but if some omnipotent bodyless
power were able to zoom in or out of our
expanding bubble they might find it to
be just a single layer of complexity in
a larger hole
and indeed one more idea is very close
to this
Robert penrose's conformal cyclic
cosmology when from our perspective our
own bubble has become infinitely large
it may simply be the seed for a new
infinitely small big bang mocking the
beginning of a Universe on an entirely
different scale foreign
[Music]
these are just theories and as with much
of the challenge of real Infinities they
are incredibly difficult if not
impossible to prove and so perhaps that
is what can save us from these
existential crises the simple fact that
the very nature of infinity means that
we could never have real evidence for an
infinite Cosmos all scientists can do is
continue to search for evidence of
finite size
keep following the turtles all the way
down
you've been watching the entire history
of the universe don't forget to like And
subscribe and leave a comment to tell us
what you think thanks for watching and
we'll see you
next
time
[Music]